est ce que votre avis l'alimentation est
un problème important est un problème
capital vital vous y attachez de
l'importance vous personnellement je ne
sais pas comme tout le monde c'est la
première servie à trimbach joue les
notations
oui enfin vous avouerez qu'on mange un
petit peu n'importe quoi la part du
double logique
comme beaucoup de français parce que
maintenant ça se généralise blues de
plus en plus j'ai plus vive depuis déjà
je suis en deuxième année
je cultive tout mon potager tout mon
jardin mon verger en culture biologique
c'était là qu'il n'y a aucun engrais
chimiques ou canada herbicides et aucun
insecticide que par exemple pour un
jardin d'une surface donnée oui ça
revient plus cher ou moins cher
d'utiliser ces produits naturels que les
produits chimiques pour n'importe quelle
surface revient beaucoup moins cher que
les que les produits chimiques
d'autre part n'ya plus d'insecticides à
employer c'est que la peine il y a plus
de pesticides d'apurer du tout on
emploie rien que ce produit là certains
produits uniques que l'on pulvérise ou
que l'on poudre sur les légumes sur les
fleurs les arbres on le fait surtout
absolument surtout c'est tellement bon
que vous pouvez en prendre dans votre
café le matin son premier public lui
avoue la tournée vous le buvez votre
tasse et ça vous fait beaucoup de bien